Square cash this episode is brought to
you by Square cash everyone is switching
to the cash app all right and that's
because it's the best way to pay people
back and most payments can be deposited
into your bank account within seconds if
you use other apps to pay people then
you're just not doing it right okay so
get the square cash app download the
free square cash app for iOS or Android
now how are you this is congratulations
I'm Chris D'Elia and this is episode 32
and I'm in Los Angeles I guess I could
stop saying that I'm always in Los
Angeles so but I'm I don't know I'd say
look first of all stop what you're doing
right now and shared the podcast all
right pause it send it to your friend
put it on Twitter put it on Instagram or
go to iTunes and rate and review it
because it helps okay you blow this
podcast up pretty soon we can take over
the world it's in a badge it's in bad
shape what do you think you think we'll
do a good job our cult so yeah so so
help me out and help no you know what
help us out it's like the the scene in
Jerry Maguire when he's like help me
help you right that's what we're doing
so yeah but I'm I'm in Los Angeles and I
I just AM hanging sometimes I don't
really know what to talk about when I
start these podcasts but then I get
going and then like by the 25 minute
mark I get real I get into a real groove
and then right as I'm getting into the
groove I decide to do my ads which ruins
it and then BAM the second half is just
decade
take a detector detector detector dude I
did jujitsu for like five years and when
when this is a while ago but when I did
it there was a guy in the class that
would go there would always teach me
stuff and he would be like and every
time he showed me a different move he'd
be like and then the arm comes around
here pink and then you do this pink and
then you move the guy over here pink and
then pink and he would always say pink
and it was so [ __ ] weird
and I and I would and I in my head I'd
be like trying to learn but I'd be like
why but he keeps saying pink and I feel
like that's why I stopped doing it and
that's why I think I'm a comedian and
not a jiu-jitsu practitioner so yeah but
it's episode 32 and I don't know man
this whole thing seems like a [ __ ]
crazy I just can't
I it's just weird to me that we've done
32 episodes but you know I looked at Joe
Rogan's thing the other day and he had
over a thousand episodes which is crazy
I did a few shows in Los Angeles for the
past week I talked to you about Utah
already but when I did this shows in Los
Angeles I did a few shows I got sick I
was on I I don't know if I everyone
always wants to be like is it the flu I
don't think it was the flu I think I
just got sick but it was annoying
because like I was like kind of sick for
a little bit and then felt okay and then
boom it hit me hard had to cancel some
shows felt really bad about that but
what you should do is go to the Comedy
Store a lot and I'm sorry that I
cancelled those shows and sometimes and
I know people drive out and I looked at
the thing about that I don't mind about
canceling sometimes when I'm sick at the
Comedy Store is you're gonna get a great
show there's gonna be [ __ ] amazing
comedians on there even if I'm not there
but I am sorry I know people drive up
sometimes from like [ __ ] San Diego or
some [ __ ] or wherever sorry I'm sorry
but you know [ __ ] happens
happens my dog is itching the [ __ ] out
of his ear which is really cool because
it's super goddamn annoying I've been
trying to put my dog on a diet one of
them is fat and he eats all the other
all the other ones food and the other
one is just like it's too like skittish
to even like sit and eat for a little
bit so while the other ones like looking
around for like ghosts I don't know it
looks like it's [ __ ] looking around
and seeing ghosts and [ __ ] that the
other one butters who's a little bit
fatter will just be like oh [ __ ] you're
looking for ghosts it's cool I'm gonna
eat the rest of your food and then
before you know it
Sam ways for four [ __ ] pounds and
butters weighs 16 pounds and it's
annoying too because whenever I call
butters Sam looks - you got one name you
piece of [ __ ] and it's Sam now butters
comes if I say butters Sam comes if I
say butters butters doesn't come if I
say Sam guy Sam [ __ ] his head so
[ __ ] hard at me whenever I say his
name or if I say want to eat or if I say
Paul oh ball is [ __ ] crazy when I say
ball he goes nuts I've never seen
another dog play with the ball like my
dog plays with the [ __ ] ball it's
insane to it I can run it in a sentence
I could be like I could say levar ball
look and he [ __ ] looks right at me
it's unbelievable ah that's a 16 year
old kid is levar the dad or the kid I
don't know but the kid whoever the kid
is is the 16 year old these guys own
shoe and the thing about the shoe is is
call it what does it called the ball
ball shoe or some [ __ ] whatever it is I
saw the shoe it's [ __ ] terrible it's
[ __ ] terrible dude levar ball looks
like a guy who would swindle you out of
all of your money and laugh so hard
about it
levar balls and dad hey your last names
ball and you play basketball that's
super weird be like if my last name was
microphone Chris microphone man
the kanye west's of [ __ ] basketball
it feels like I like how he had
seven-year-olds and he was like they
could be Michael Jordan 7mm sports
people are crazy about [ __ ] sports
people are crazy about sports I was
thinking about sports the other day and
it's crazy how people literally live
their lives first things like basketball
and football but then when it comes down
to it and here's why I don't play I
don't play games and I don't mean like
how rappers say like I'll play games I
mean like literally I don't play games
because I can't wrap my head around how
it's something that somebody some other
guy just created the rules for and then
I got a [ __ ] play what you're you
said like oh you don't put the [ __ ]
you put the ball through the hoop and
then the other team gets the ball and
then you can't go on the other side and
then you can't take a few steps without
dribbling and what hey huh
nah let's just chill yeah but oh you
can't wear those colors sneakers Oh what
hey I'll just chill yeah but you can't
stand in the key for more than three
seconds and if you shoot it outside of
here at straight points huh
snow points its no points no matter what
ball no matter what [ __ ] basket you
make it's no points in life it's zero
points in life it's zero points in life
so when somebody is at a party and
brings out taboo burn it cuz it's zero
points in life man all the [ __ ]
things
I just and then so there were like the
five sports or whatever there was
baseball football basketball I don't
know like [ __ ] tennis and then I
guess so I'm not being a [ __ ] idiot
whatever their one is that they play and
[ __ ] Europe probably for centuries
that I don't know about you know some
[ __ ] [ __ ] game that they probably
play in Europe that's way bigger than
any women's soccer but besides soccer
there's probably another one where it's
like they have some [ __ ] what's that
what's that dummy [ __ ] sport where they
have that big curvy [ __ ] catcher and
they [ __ ] grab the ball with the
curvy catcher and then throw it at a
wall hey man get rid of that big curvy
[ __ ] catcher what is that [ __ ]
stupid game called highligh is hey it's
not around anymore right
is it hi Ally dude the [ __ ] out here
first of all call it something ball okay
don't just make up some [ __ ] highlight
also spelled with a J catch you later
spell it with an H dude look how dumb
high lie is hi Ally and then they have
just Google Image hi Ally
spell it however the [ __ ] you want it
will come up Google will prop it's about
so [ __ ] up Google will be like did did
did you mean a high high by did you and
then they have helmets on go [ __ ] your
and then long white pants go [ __ ]
yourself what is that
Heil I India pale what the [ __ ]
it's a dev a drink hi Ally India Pale
Ale ah the worst drink of all time hey
drink highlight India Pale Ale tastes
like curry and sports tastes like curry
and balls dude highlights so dumb if you
have to [ __ ] work that look at that
dumb [ __ ] wicker catcher dude that
looks like you sit in it and they take a
school photo Wow woah dude [ __ ] that
imagine putting that big-ass thing on
your arm and trying to catch some [ __ ]
and then throw it at a wall and and then
and then and that became big that sport
became big and people would not only
play it but watch people play it and not
laugh and go like this Oh unbelievable
hi Ally hi and bye that's what it should
be called look at these [ __ ] video it
video these [ __ ] playing it and look
at these [ __ ] they swing it from
below [ __ ]
Wow Orlando Heil I these guys are
[ __ ] the other and I heard them so so
bad you know has so many shoulder
problems by the way this one guy has a
[ __ ] Jersey on on the back he's
number 40 on the front it's six hey man
what number are yet [ __ ] yo what are you
number six or number 40
are you team six it's a confusing the
whole thing is so confusing why do you
have a helmet on if in case the wicker
basket hit you in the [ __ ] head
nah you're gonna be fine dude
so they [ __ ] make these sports and
then people are like yeah sports we and
then and then you live your life devoted
to this [ __ ] football [ __ ] or
baseball [ __ ] or highlight [ __ ] or
whatever and then and then that's your
life you you're devoted to somebody else
who created a game I don't know that's
all I'm saying
it's a little bit kouddous [ __ ] it's a
little bit kudus [ __ ] and I know that
people are gonna be like oh degree but
definition of a coder swatch are um yeah
so I mean how about [ __ ] my thing the
thing is when here's how you know sports
the basic sports or are a little bit
kind of dated is when the [ __ ] in the
80s and [ __ ] when extreme sports started
first of all don't don't ever
the word extreme before any of your
[ __ ] okay because it's not alright
everything is what what skating what are
you [ __ ] what do you doing what's an
extreme sport look up extreme sports
like what is it what are you [ __ ]
what is it like skiing with a [ __ ]
you know but it's like my whole thing is
is like the more extreme the sport gets
the crazier the [ __ ] person involved
is and then they're like [ __ ] there's
so much into it and like I get footballs
away a life but it's more of like a like
a culture and let's like a family thing
and like you can grow up playing it and
[ __ ] like that but extreme sports with
like BMX racing and flipping around and
[ __ ] like and like skydiving and [ __ ]
burning yourself on fire like those guys
get [ __ ] nuts and then and then those
guys are like those guys are like if I
like a guy who plays football if he
didn't play football if he if he had
like a [ __ ] injury and then couldn't
play football for the rest of his life
he'd be like so depressed and maybe even
catatonic for the rest of his life but
if somebody couldn't play like [ __ ]
water jetting or whatever the [ __ ] an
extreme sport would be called and we're
like ripcord is we're like flying or
what's that [ __ ] flying thing that
they do with the hey you would wingsuit
the wingsuit [ __ ] that they do like
if guys if guys who live to do that
can't do that anymore I feel like they
literally [ __ ] kill themselves and
they'd be like like extreme sports where
you can die while doing it like they
they'd be like hey I'd do it if I can't
put on my wings of the day I can't put
on my wingsuit is the day I [ __ ] jump
off a goddamn building without my
wingsuit
and and and like but even like
skateboarding has a little bit about
that [ __ ]
we're talking why did why like what is
skate like what is skate or die the word
or has never meant less than skate or
Die okay because there is everything in
between skateboarding and dying for
instance eatin a turkey sandwich you
don't have to [ __ ] skate it's like
that's not an option
hey dude what do you want to do today
yeah I mean you know skate or die I
guess oh [ __ ] I was thinking about going
to the mall well that's not skating or
dying that's a real [ __ ] dumb don't
if I'm a skateboarder and this is
probably why I'm not a skateboarder and
somebody [ __ ] did you why can't it
just be like ripping you know and
[ __ ] this house skate or die thing
Skinner died dude if i didn't have my
[ __ ] board take me if you [ __ ]
like surfing and [ __ ] like fighting over
waves fighting over ways my producer
just turned on his phone one fire one
fire yeah I don't get it
that whole [ __ ] I that whole culture
is so [ __ ] annoying to me it's so
secretly beta even though it's alpha
it's sooo beta because it's like you're
not recognizing what char is a man that
hold no fear [ __ ]
hey fear no fear hey guess what fear
that whole clothing line when that [ __ ]
came out when I was [ __ ] 14 no fear
when it's like [ __ ] crocodile staring
you in the face and your hands are tied
behind your back
and you're in a room [ __ ] fear yeah
yeah dude your gun died and that's okay
sweat char a male with fear fears good
fears good fear keeps you alive okay if
you had no fear
then you [ __ ] wouldn't put on a
seatbelt in your car you do it if you
had no fear if you had no fear you'd
walk around with your [ __ ] pants off
and dick out
just getting rested scared cops no I
hate that [ __ ]
also you're just some guy in a high
school that's wearing that shirt that
goes to class you know no fear fear I
want to make sure it's that say fear I'm
scared I'm scared of some things no fear
with the [ __ ] mean eyes and [ __ ]
the graphics but here's one good click
on that one seconds left what's the one
on the right all the way on the right
five seconds left at the three-point
line down by two five four three two one
no fear
hey man it's not that scary even at
least [ __ ] trying to make it scary
second second
is the first loser no fear siga life's
not too short it's just that you're dead
for so long no fear see ya hey you're a
beta hey get under me look up hey dude
have your knees touch the ground look up
macaques above you fear hey man
chin up balls are a foot from your face
fear it he's scared cuz MS can cover
your face you're scared cuz from gay
come trip on your face no fear fear plus
a lot of those guys who [ __ ] scream
that no fear alpha [ __ ] guess what
you're scared of
dick fear fear of your bro putting his
arm around you cuz you hum folk skate or
die now also you could just chill dylan
then then then skate or die but also you
can just go see a movie or something but
land then then then skate or die but
also sometimes big bang theory is on a
marathon peddling ting ting ting
dude have you seen the young Sheldon
[ __ ] billboards dude I was talking
about origin stories all right fine
if you're gonna have an aura dude Winnie
the Pooh's having an origin story uh
step out of the room for a second heck
gunk now they're making a [ __ ] guy
from Big Bang Theory origin story which
okay fine
step out gunk free conch but change it
cuz what char tsukuda now I had to hit
you with that [ __ ] congratulations
combo but now I don't even really have a
problem make shows about whatever you
had the [ __ ] Gotham show my buddy Ben
Mackenzie's in the [ __ ] show about
Batman is it's about the origin story
about [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is the
detective on Batman Commissioner Gordon
yeah alright fine
cool whatever I get it make an origin
story fine but uh the the the whiteness
of the billboard of young Sheldon like
I've never seen like that billboard of
the young Sheldon billboard for CBS I've
never seen a show that literally zero
minorities would watch after seeing that
[ __ ] billboard that that [ __ ]
little like white kid that that like
literally like it's it's unbelievable
with the [ __ ] button up shirt oh my
god what's the kid's name is that Ian
Ian Armitage a slight I mean fine the
kid looks like Hitler Youth what oh well
he's seven so I'm not gonna make fun of
them but you know it's not it's not him
it's not him but they dressed him up in
like a tie and then see these
kids who have these [ __ ] parents that
run their Facebook pages and [ __ ] e now
it's cool but I'm gonna I'm gonna
elongate this for you because you really
needs they're really nice to st. I'm
Sinkin but if you're a parent dude the
way the kid it the way they told the kid
to hold the [ __ ] tie on the Billboard
for the young Sheldon billboard and he's
doing it like this where he's holding
the [ __ ] tie and he's [ __ ] putting
his arms up I mean it is so [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he's seven but they now let me tell
you what you're doing to this kid
whether you're this kid's parent whether
you're this kid's producer with you
either writing on the show for the kid
whether you're [ __ ] acting with the
kid and I'm gonna elongate this for you
because it needs to sink in and I want
you to be ready when I'm saying when I
say what I'm saying but here we go
E
you ruin his life
okay you ruining his life he's seven he
let me hit a few notes - ay-yi-yi rune
in his life I hope this show goes for 47
years
sirs get so much [ __ ] money
because your own in his life that kid is
gonna be 12 okay and walk into if the
shows on and walk into a room and
there's going to be like men and women
in there and like like you know 25 year
old women and he's gonna be like BJ now
and then Oklahoma and then we and then
whoever was like handling him is gonna
be like whatever his name is Sheldon or
no Ian you can't do that he's gonna say
BJ now and they wouldn't want on a BJ
and some [ __ ] lemonade
irin in his life with the billboard dude
I don't know I'm going to hell for
saying that that [ __ ] billboard
drives me nuts have him sit chillin on a
chair just have him kickin it there's a
theme of bitchiness
this [ __ ] episode dude it's fine to
be a [ __ ] like I don't even know what
I'm trying to say don't don't be a
[ __ ] just don't play up the [ __ ]
Ness
but also have fear you know there's like
a line in there somewhere
don't be a [ __ ] alpha ass
[ __ ]
that's like you know you scared of [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] skate or die
well I'll live for the waves you know
but then also don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
on Facebook that [ __ ] post something
like I'd be nothing without my wife hey
it's fine if you think that keep to
yourself it's fine if you think my wife
is my world but keep it to yourself you
know why cuz you look like a [ __ ]
CUDA when you're posting it dude
like how about people that like I just I
don't I don't know it's so hard to say
this without coming off as some as
saying like I don't mean like III value
when like them like if a man has a job
and a woman has a job and you go and if
the man's the breadwinner fine whatever
that's how it's been for [ __ ]
centuries I get it and like it's you
know men try and like you know are the
historically men have been the providers
monetarily and [ __ ] with with goods
and [ __ ] food and [ __ ] and then the
women are there are the caretakers and
raise the families and I get that and
the patriarchy and all that [ __ ] and I
know how a lot of it is bad and I get it
I don't know why I started saying this
but okay yeah I I don't know what I was
saying I've been doing this I think I'm
gonna have all servers when I'm older
but um don't you know but just the sheer
[ __ ] nosov being like I'd be nothing
without my wife it reeks of you trying
to make reparations for the [ __ ]
centuries and first of all you're young
person snot you fault okay that they've
been doing that and you are it feels
like you say that because you're guilty
and even if you don't and even if you
mean it if you posted it on Facebook
seems like you're saying it because you
feel guilty therefore don't say it keep
to yourself otherwise you look like a
supreme a supreme [ __ ]
you need to get one of those shirts that
say supreme with the red bars on it and
under it say [ __ ] and then online
bottom says fear don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] dude but also
have fear like those guys that are just
like my wife is my world yeah dude we
know man stop rubbing it in my face
I know okay dude my business is thriving
but if I couldn't have my wife and my
family I'd give it all up in a blink of
an eye
hey dude go [ __ ] yourself
I know we know we know families what
matters shut up shut up on Facebook okay
shut up on your Instagram story shut up
write a book about it write a [ __ ]
book about it you CUDA don't [ __ ]
post it on Facebook cuz yeah you get the
itch cuz you feel like you know what
here world send here world
here's
[ __ ] gold nugget for you Family
Matters
with a [ __ ] emoji heart [ __ ] eyes
eat my [ __ ] dude you ruining lives it's
not that easy
you gotta [ __ ] work write a book
about it or don't post your doctor the
doctor of love are you some guy that
works at Wells Fargo no cool then don't
post my wife is my world dude because we
know alright uh just like that [ __ ]
emo [ __ ] I'm actually getting faint
talking about this that's how passionate
I am right now I'd be nothing without my
wife yeah dude we get it she'd be
nothing without you either
you'd be nothing without her because
you'd be some lonely [ __ ] jerk-off in
a [ __ ] you know yeah maybe you'd be
working out you know when you're talking
about the patriarchy whatever maybe
you'd be working at the top [ __ ]
floor of a building and you have the
whole [ __ ] floor to yourself marble
[ __ ] floors saunas [ __ ] just come
and getting sucked and [ __ ] sounds
like a great [ __ ] live actually not
gonna think about it
but it's just looking out at the
building just thinking about I own
[ __ ] places out there too
just gettin
sucked you know but lonely is [ __ ] on
the inside lonely and broken and fifty
and wishing maybe you had a family now
you too old you're not gonna play catch
with your 11 year old son when you 61
cuz your knees are gonna hurt should
have done it already but it shows you
chose to kept getting sucked instead of
raising the family
you chose to kept to keep getting sucked
okay so if you didn't do that you got a
family yeah that's who you'd be that's
who you'd be you'd be the guy standing
on the top floor of the [ __ ] tallest
tower in New York with a business suit
on
except for your pants will be dropped
and you'd be getting sucked by a 22 year
old be lonely cuz after she leaves you
just got a watch like [ __ ] ESPN
SportsCenter now I know that still
sounds like a great life but does it
though but does it though I don't know I
don't know I'm not 61 I'm thirty [ __ ]
seven I don't know I don't know I know
people who have it that way and then
also have it the other way and live with
a [ __ ] family and love their family
and wouldn't have it any other way
hey Sam don't bark at me I know you
disagree with me cuz you like you like
you like family because you're my family
I get it my dogs barking at me and it's
very cute but also you're a woman and
you know just talking about the
patriarchy if you're a woman and you
stayed at home and yeah and yeah and
yeah and you were just loving you know
your your your uh your family and you
did all the [ __ ] dirty work as a mom
and you were there for your kids and you
raised these kids and these kids
would've literally died if it wasn't for
you and your your you you you you and
you know you cook for your husband and
when they come home the dinner's ready
and and
[Music]
yeah yeah we get it you don't have to
[ __ ] say you'd be nothing without
your husband even though you'd probably
[ __ ] I feel like the women would
[ __ ] still make it but the husband
would be the [ __ ] lonely one you know
because the women have the kids would
side with the women because they're
[ __ ] better with just kind of all
around you know because they care more
and dudes are [ __ ] selfish as [ __ ]
but yeah just with the e-motion
I guess is what I'm saying I don't know
I tried trailed off and I forget what my
point is but whatever anyway anyway
families are important lifts knows what
their drivers are oops lifts knows that
their drivers are what keep them moving
literally so they do everything they can
to make sure their drivers are happy on
every trip it's a simple formula
honestly happy drivers mean happy
passengers
maybe that's why nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating
lift was the first ride share platform
with tipping built right into the app
okay it you know you don't carry
crumpled up bills and all that so just
they get to do it on the app you keep a
hundred percent of the tips if you ride
for lyft and they add up fast drivers
have been paid over $200 two hundred
million dollars since the feature was
first introduced two hundred million
dollars lyft has taken the guesswork out
of pickups the new amp device uses color
coding to help passengers find their
drivers so it's super easy for you join
the ride-sharing company that believes
in treating its people better go to lift
calm / congrats today and you can get a
$500 new driver bonus that's lift calm /
congrats lift calm / Congrats limited
time only terms apply five for the five
for club understands that your time is
extremely valuable why wasted at the
mall or wandering rat
around in stores who does that what is
this 1988 its 2017 5-4 has been leading
menswear for over 15 years you can trust
them with your wardrobe I do each month
they send you a curator box at two to
three items that are hand-picked to
match the current season and your style
I like the stuff they send me they know
what they're doing so if you don't
that's ok I know what I'm doing okay I
like fashion I know what I'm doing and I
still use them alright so they'll help
you with it you know one more month at a
time they send you stuff you can get 120
dollar worth of clothes for just $60 a
month you could live lavish for half the
price
laws are canceled any time you receive
up to 50% as a five-four club member 50%
off items in their online shop and
access to members only items free
shipping size exchanges go to five for
club.com right now and enter promo code
Congrats that's for us and they'll give
you 50% off your first month's package
plus a free pair of sunglasses oh so
you'll be cool and you keep the Sun out
of your eyes as well is this a dream
is this a dream no 50% off of your first
package at five four clubs about fi ve
fo you are club.com promo code Congrats
five for club.com promo code Congrats
Square cash everyone is switching to the
cash app because it's the best way to
pay people back friends family
co-workers co-workers ghosts anyone
really sending and receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly into the bank
account in seconds here's how it works
you dingus download the square cash app
even though you're already dead because
you're not an idiot and if you are do it
now link your debit or credit card
select an amount to send and type in a
friend's phone number or email address
to complete a payment they'll get a
notification that they've just received
money and that's it no gimmick
okay square cash is cool because it's
not a social network all right you're
not gonna have a guy that sends you
money and be like oh my wife is my world
as the status update and then everyone's
gonna see that your wife is your world
and you sent you why $40 for groceries
you can do it on the sly who wants to
have their payments listed in a feed
nobody so download the free square cash
app for iOS or Android now that's all
I'm trying to say do it that's all I'm
trying to say so I'm trying to say um
say yeah I was pulling into [ __ ] I
went to write eight to get some [ __ ]
appointment I put that word when we
change it and I mean point you know so I
[ __ ] went to get some ointment and
and I turned out of the thing and this
guy was pulling in and he had a [ __ ]
like old like classic he looking kind of
[ __ ] GP type [ __ ] [ __ ] that
any any any girl that saw that would be
like oh man that's the car so cool like
in their head
this car is a car that like a lot of
guys would like but every girl would
would like imagines that like if they're
22 they imagine them dating a thirty
[ __ ] three-year-old that drives this
kind of car because it's like an older
like classic e-type [ __ ] a nice paint
job with no roof and the [ __ ] roll
bars but it was like from the 70s or
some [ __ ] and this guy was a blonde [ __ ]
oh and he was driving into the Rite Aid
like I hope he was trying to [ __ ]
herpes medication you know because this
[ __ ] guy with this car dude
when people get off on like classic cars
here's a deal first of all if you got
six cars and one of them is a classic
car cool
you collect cars that's great and you
got your [ __ ] fun little tooling
around classic car with a nice paint job
but if that's your car a classic car
you're a you're an [ __ ]
you're an [ __ ] because we've invented
things and I understand that sometimes
things get worse okay like I guess you
know a lot of basketball shoes have
gotten better but some of them you know
they say well yeah but it's a maximum
production now and and you know the
leather was better on the [ __ ] thing
and that in his and ankle injuries went
up a lot since the [ __ ] introduction
of the the air soul and all that [ __ ]
and fine okay
but most of us are just walking around
not playing basketball so if you have a
classic car and you got some money and
that's your only car drive it into a
wall slowly so you don't get hurt
the ruin it and get a car that has
[ __ ] bluetooth okay get a car that
makes life easier for you you [ __ ] oh
okay get a car that has air conditioning
that when you [ __ ] press it it
doesn't go
get a car with the seats feel
comfortable and not like a dragon is
[ __ ] you in your butt okay
get a car that isn't too long you know
those [ __ ] classic cars that are just
too long
[ __ ] those cars and then you give it to
a valet guy and the valet guys like I
don't know I get on top of a hill
somewhere so nobody [ __ ] if you if
you have one of those long ass classic
cars that's like probably I get Cadillac
or some [ __ ] and if you got and if
somebody [ __ ] crosses into you even
if you're parked your fault
it's your fault your cars too long your
car's too long okay hey hey is your
[ __ ] hey is your car Michael Caine's
courier or is it a car oh it's a car
then it's too long dude hey is your car
[ __ ] Michael Caine's career dude dude
was your car in [ __ ] Cider House
Rules oh oh it wasn't dude oh okay then
don't drive it then
oh no then drive it because it's not
Michael Caine's career I'm doing this
I just have to look at Michael Caine hey
was you was did your car play [ __ ]
Bruce Wayne's Butler in the Dark Knight
or does it just have four wheels and
drive you to Whole Foods cool then it's
a car make it shorter
dude Michael Caine's in everything I
literally could have picked a movie and
it would have been I mean he's in
everything dude
I mean he's even in Dunkirk as an
uncredited voice like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
I got a Bay in Dunkirk is there a movie
coming out worse Michael Caine
impression of all time Fonda whatever
[ __ ] all over that director that I
walked if we're [ __ ] out the Dark
Knight for there if there's a spot I
could fit in there so bad uh who Michael
Caine has a website that's hilarious you
know he literally had nothing to do with
it Michael Caine has a website Wow the
official website of Sir Michael Caine
first of all if you're a sir dude if I
I'll never become a sir but if anyone
ever [ __ ] anointed me and I became a
sir and anyone ever called me sir Chris
D'Elia I'd [ __ ] say hey man just call
me Chris okay dude look at all the
movies he's been in this guy you know he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about any of them
too especially the later ones so funny
dude like he was in now you see me too
you know and they're like
they were like hey Michael Caine his
agents were like do you will you feel
like they want you to do all do it no
well this is the I'll do it
okay all right they want you to fly to
Aldo it I don't care though I I'll do
any movie you ever want me to do okay
Zach Braff's doing and directing a movie
called going against Aldo it ho Zach
Braff I'll do it he was in scrubs walk
scrubs I'll do it
scrubs our show on NBC was a big hit
what NBC I was it was on TV
watch TV I'll do it they'll give you 19
million dollars
I'll down care I'll do it okay hey
they're doing a movie called the
Kingsmen although it would you want to
hear what it's about and I they want to
fly you to although it hey hey they want
hey they want you to be an interstellar
obviously I'll do it I feel like in
scripts it just says Michael Caine it
doesn't even and then they and then they
shoot it and then when they're shooting
it they're like let's have his name be
[ __ ] Harry Brown let's have his name
be [ __ ] Hobbs I mean I [ __ ]
I turn on the prestige the other day
he's just he's in that obviously imagine
having a movie called the prestige and
[ __ ] Michael Caine's not in it it's
called the prestige all our agents yeah
I heard there's a movie of our code the
prestige what a [ __ ] bloody LM or not
in it oh well we'll get old do it yeah
yeah okay just tell him I'll do it well
there's not a part for a guy your age
rotted in okay
Hildy the guy said he'll write it in no
[ __ ] I'm Michael Caine I mean how much
has honestly Michael Caine for real said
like at this point how much is he
honestly said what's he internet how
much is he [ __ ] honestly said that
really I bet he said it seven times and
I'm talking about when it first came out
or whatever and it was this internet and
then they were like oh it's like
connected a bunch of connected computers
and it's like a network and and you can
share it like communication and
knowledge and all that [ __ ] alright and
then like a week later he was like yeah
you're about the scene in that thing
what is it again and then that was the
second time and then they were like oh
it's the thing where the computers are
so raw raw yeah yeah la I they set me up
with an and and an a lol account and he
was like no it's a oh L raw raw raw and
then somebody and then like three days
later would he heard about AOL and he
was like oh is that that thing that's a
lot of computers and they're like what
and they're like what is it cold and
he's like the the internet and he's like
yeah yeah what he's that and then he's
like oh yeah it's like the computer and
then like so he kind of knew what it was
but then like a few years later he
[ __ ] stop using it you know because
it was like 93 and he was like just
doing [ __ ] mr. destiny and [ __ ]
noises off and the movie blue ice and
the Muppet Christmas Carol and and and
and and then [ __ ] and then [ __ ] he
did them in and and then and they forgot
and then someone was like I'll email it
to you
and he was like what he's died they were
like what's what and they're like an
email and they was like oh it's like I
don't have an AOL and he's like oh yeah
I got a lol and they're like no it's a
o-l and he's like what would I call that
and they're like you mean the internet
he's a what he's da and that was like
the fourth time or third or fourth time
and then it just happened a few like a
few years after that and then like the
last time he did it was like in 2011 was
like the seventh time somebody was like
you know you should get a web site I
mean I know you have like a great career
everything but like you know them you
know it'd be cool like Gnomeo and Juliet
is coming out and you're obviously a
voice in that because they would never
make that movie without you doing the
voice because there's somebody called
Lord redbrick in it so you know and you
said you'll do it so [ __ ] before
[ __ ] Cars 2 goes into production
because you're obviously going to play
Finn McMissile I guess
you should probably get a website he
said oh no it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
you know a homepage that you could have
on the internet and he said or see you
[ __ ] swear to [ __ ] god [ __ ] that
happened [ __ ] seven times whatever
helps you know and then they were like
yeah well you can have things on there
like you know you can have my Michael
Caine news that people will go to and by
this time it's like way too late for a
[ __ ] [ __ ] website anyway because
like everyone has Instagram [ __ ] like
that go back up go back up and you'll
have all the home for all your [ __ ] and
you know you have like [ __ ] you go to
the website it be Michael Caine calm and
then you have the Michael Caine news and
you have Michael Caine you have like a
biography about you they don't have a
place to go for a filmography even
though nobody will check it because I am
DB exists and then we'll have like a
place where you can brag about like your
achievements and so call down bragging
and it like no you don't actually have
to do it we'll do it and then you know
we'll have like your your [ __ ]
timeline and then it'll be cool because
we'll be able to put your books on there
which nobody even knows that you have
but you have obviously because you're
[ __ ] 90 years old and you definitely
wrote some books because you're too
famous because people who are 90 years
old and that famous obviously have
written books and then also we'll put up
a gallery and we'll put your favorite
pictures on there and he says all right
and then and if you go to Michael
Caine's gallery it's got to go to
Michael Caine's website and go together
he's got and one is of course of him in
black and white because he's been alive
since cameras existed I'll put two okay
Michael can you send us your favorite
pictures I'll do it can you send us your
favorite pick out their life two
favorite pictures oh cool can you email
it to us wha
never mind just I'll come over and get
them and scan them what scan and nothing
it's fine you can get it through the
internet oh I'm not gonna ask for a days
but I think I think I know where he is
because that was the seventh time that
was the last time you did it oh [ __ ] a
gallery dude how funny is it when
somebody has a gallery on their website
and it has two pictures I mean one
picture is a fear and then it's got
different faces of him like throughout
the years but not really though it's
kind of only like well I guess one is in
his 20s and ones maybe now now ish but
then while the other ones is of him get
his haircut like what is that it's still
from a movie I guess right has to be oh
god who put this [ __ ] website
together dude [ __ ] Ray Charles Finn
McMissile that's like so offensive you
know yeah we'll get Michael Caine to do
it obviously
why that's Finn McMissile what is that
what couldn't be found
oh great Michael Caine has a [ __ ]
thing on the bottom of his West Side
website that says useful links and you
click on it and it says sorry this page
could not be found
[ __ ] I'm sweating I'm laughing so hard
oh [ __ ] that that is the hardest I've
left on the website are on the podcast
website oh my god oh my god I mean the
movies this guy's been in and the movie
the the movies that sound like movies he
would be in are unbelievable
the quiet american course Michael Caine
would be in that the actors of course
Michael Caine would be in that second
second second hand Lions course he'd be
in that freedom a history of us of
course he'd be in that I mean do it my
producer is surfing around on this guy's
website Michael Caine's web website and
it literally I mean what the [ __ ] how is
that the quote okay so Michael Caine is
called the elephant to Hollywood by the
way did he write this book
maybe not whatever it's a book about him
it's an autobiography so he did all
right the quote that's you know I like
there's a quote that's like the best
book I've ever read or like one of the
top [ __ ] autobiographies of this
generation the quote that they're Pro
mowing this book to get you to want to
read it I [ __ ] you're not on the on the
website is and I quote a very British
star of there
British star what the [ __ ] is that his
name oh my god his real name is mmm well
okay I mean his real name is more
British than [ __ ] Finn McMissile and
Lord and [ __ ] whatever it was you
could his real name is so British
you could put Lord in front of it and it
would make it less British his name
could be [ __ ] London Manchester and
it would be less British than this this
is his [ __ ] real name Maurice Mikkel
white it's been a long journey for
Maurice Nicoll white born with rickets
and London's poverty stricken Elephant &
Castle to the bright lights of Hollywood
the most British sentence of all time
rickets
you know rickets in London's poverty
stricken Elephant & Castle what is it
what is it oh my god dude and the
picture of him on this foot of him
pointing Michael Caine the Elephant
Hollywood the autobiography and the
picture of him why would you if your
Michael Caine why would you write a book
I mean I understand people might want to
read it but why do you give a [ __ ] I
don't understand I don't understand a
very British star it's the thing that
they have in quotes what was that is
that another book down there he wrote
another book he wrote he wrote two
autobiographies hey man wait till later
and to write only one and also this is
the most British quote they're trying to
present charm and humor of natural
recontour and guess if humor has a you
in it
Maurice Mikkel why
you bet look at how they try to make it
another one - come on dude
it's nun autobiography thank God oh wow
is the other more there's not more guys
got three books okay I mean give us a
[ __ ] these guys who write books it's
like it doesn't I don't understand
you make what a million dollars what
this guy's got to have [ __ ] 35 houses
I mean what's he worth oh cool he's
worth 75 million dollars cool hey you
were 75 million dollars
don't write a book the [ __ ] dude if I'm
worth 75 million no how much of that is
his book three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars guarantee it if that if
that look at look at look at look at the
things that are top searched on his
thing where does Michael Caine live in
London how many children does Michael
Caine have where is Michael Caine born
what was Michael Caine's first movie
it's so funny that if it was a 20 year
old actor you looked up it would be like
Zac Efron's [ __ ] Zac Efron's girlfriend
and a Zac Efron gay it's so funny man
because those are British people what
does Michael Caine live in London does
Michael Caine know what the internet is
look it look it look it look at his
Twitter unbelievable huh this is a sneak
brag just saw Dunkirk you must see it
and then [ __ ] the same the same day
hope you're all having the best summer
beautiful day in London my favorite city
enjoy your weekend everyone and guess if
favorite has au in it Wow
he's [ __ ] I mean I know I'm making
fun of him he is awesome Michael [ __ ]
Kane dude Maurice and Michael white I
love this going in style in cinemas and
then 47 spaces 7th April not April 7th
7th April that's probably do it in
Britain right probably
let's hope so let's [ __ ] hope so that
this guy isn't solo I don't give a [ __ ]
where the day goes and where the month
goes they'll get it all right
books 7th I bro put that on the internet
oh my god
hello exclamation point my film going in
style is funny you must see it opening
soon and then here's another tweet best
of wishes hey man
it's nothing what you did was literally
like breathing oh my god this tweet I
will continue L will continue to have
the best time hope you do the same huh
somebody writes thanks Mike like it was
just to him oh wow alright this part guy
I'm so sweating I might skip the [ __ ]
hashtags and the [ __ ] most [ __ ] up
Instagram of the week no I mean I'm so
it's [ __ ] we're over an hour and I'm
[ __ ] sweating like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is one of my favorite episodes
I'll do it the [ __ ] oh my god [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] so sweaty
[ __ ] thanks for listening alright I'll
do the [ __ ] segments next week all
right I got some closing statements here
first of all Square cash if you switched
yet
download the free square cash out for
iOS or Android now it's uh it's great
you got to get square cash hook it up go
download it now don't be don't be coda
now I got some things that are are some
issues here we just had a [ __ ] good
time okay now from a cult I got some
[ __ ] duties here okay rate and review
the podcast please it means a lot tweet
it means a lot to rate and review and
share this podcast because if the
podcast doesn't grow just like any other
business it's gonna die if this podcast
doesn't continue to grow it's going to
die and I'm telling you that I'm telling
you this podcast is going to die if it
doesn't grow now picture me standing on
a [ __ ] raised platform behind a
podium with one of those thin ass little
[ __ ] stringing mics saying this to
you and you're in a yard because this is
some serious cult [ __ ] to it if this
podcast doesn't grow it's going to die
and this cult is over
no elders no nothing so rate and review
and tweet this podcast and Instagram
this podcast and tell your friends about
this
okay upcoming shows on my website you
can go to my website it is not half as
good or one-quarter as funny as Michael
Caine's website but go and check out my
dates Phoenix Arizona Tempe Arizona New
Brunswick New Jersey Boone North
Carolina Charlotte North Carolina
Adelaide you know sorry I got Adelaide
Perth Melbourne Sydney Brisbane and in
Ohio in November I have Columbus Irvine
California in November to December San
Jose California San Jose California
December 7th get these tickets they're
going fast and I also am doing a show
that is he that is a benefit for
hurricane Harvey I'm doing it tomorrow
on Tuesday tomorrow on Tuesday in Austin
there might still be some tickets left
some of them are high-dollar tickets for
the front row because all of the
proceeds go to hurricane Harvey and
donating for this terrible disaster that
happened and I'm doing this because I
need to I really want to help because
what those [ __ ] families are going
through is just horrible man what what
what what's happened in Houston and I
feel terrible for it if you can't get to
the show that's fine donate if you can
even a little bit even though dollar or
two if everyone does that it really
helps I donated be like me and in that
way not in other ways but it just it
helps man these people [ __ ] got their
families torn apart and I mean the
images are just all awful and my heart
goes out to these people man I just I
hope I hope that you know they can get
using me if they're [ __ ] together soon
man it's [ __ ] awful what happened
they're saying it's the worst thing the
storm that happened in a thousand years
that's like some biblical [ __ ] some [ __ ]
you'd hear on Game of Thrones you know
the storm of a thousand years and
Michael Caine would be in it but yeah
dude
try and help out please and you only
have to send money send [ __ ] you can
send [ __ ] I put a link up on my Facebook
page where you can send stuff like
diapers and toothpaste just anything
people are going without showers they
need soap so you could send package care
packages it's just it's it's great so
yeah so even if you don't rate review do
that don't don't even rate and review
the podcast do that it's much more
important all right you can find me at
Chris D'Elia calm and congratulations
calm or a congrats pod or at Chris
D'Elia thanks everybody
you guys are my babies remember that
catch you soon bye